non ça c'est tout moi super six
ah lalala lalala
bonsoir bonsoir j'ai réussi à moto
éjecté de mon propre live voilà salut
salut salut je sais qu'il ya plusieurs
motifs bref la planification du live
c'est c'est pas encore ça sur le youtube
studio je vais essayer de remettre le
lien quelque part sur les réseaux parce
que sinon ça va être ça va être
complètement foiré on entend hockey un
live de 26 secondes
j'ai réussi à me lancer live et puis à
en sortir
voilà un gros faux pas que j'essaye de
prévoir des trucs ça marche jamais ça
n'est jamais bon soir bonsoir bonsoir
les hautes-alpes
c'est un deuxième live deuxième manche
puis une aise non mais je suis là tu
voudrais faire ça tu arriverais pas
alors bon bah écoute et voilà premier
live de la série j'ai voulu faire ça
parce que bon on est à peu près à la
moitié de la série bat mais même plus à
la moitié ouais en fin de journée pour
moi je j'arrive il ya 4 4 épisodes sur
sept qui sont sortis voilà le prochain
il arrive pas ce lundi celui d'après
donc ce sera le jacques seck là que le
24 j'essaye de vous lire en même temps à
google à artcurial s'éteint c'est un
certain c'est mon assistant il peut pas
rester bon bon bon bon courage pour le
boulot et puis il y aura la rediffusion
donc dans ce live
moi je vous propose un live faq d'accord
voilà je réponds à vos questions que ce
soit archéo ou monde cinématographique
tout cas je pourrais expliquer mes choix
comme angers comment j'ai monté cette
série voilà tout ce qui toutes les
questions que vous posez sur le tournage
l'écriture la postproduction le montage
et puis la suite
alors je vais je parlerai pas des trois
prochains épisodes ça je garde
je garde la surprise ça rien de temps
vous pouvez le demander est ce que ce
sera mais je vous dirai pas ça je me
suis je suis premier premier promis et
et voilà une faq j'ai préparé un petit
concours pour vous faire gagner des
petites choses de voilà je voulais on a
essayé avec l'illustrateur christophe
christophe fournier de le faire
intervenir dans le live mais il n'est
pas dispo donc ce sera peut-être pour le
second je pense que je ferai un deuxième
live de conclusion de cette série et
voilà et puis oui je vous parlerai aussi
de la soirée de projection une soirée je
vous ai promis au lancement de la
campagne
hull qui devait être une soirée
d'avant-première pour vous pour vous
proposer en avant première les deux
premiers épisodes c'était ça le projet
au départ et puis il ya eu qu'ovide et
donc tout a été décalé et finalement ce
sera une soirée de projection de
l'intégralité de la série avec un
nouveau montage c'est à dire qui aura
pas de coupure entre les épisodes ce
sera un long métrage plus de 70 minutes
donc avec pas trop de réécriture mais un
peu de remontage
alors on en train de travailler ça en ce
moment
alors as que je pars des modérateurs
l'escargot jeanne laissé un mot sur
l'autre instance live en attente pour
rediriger ici alors hier ramener les
gens ici moi je suggère yves tual
retrouvez le live jeu
alors j'ai une question qui n'a rien à
voir avec le live donc jeudi avant ouais
quand tu continuais le vortex
alors ben non sauf si on me demande moi
j'ai été programmé pour la première
saison que j'ai donc honoré mais j'ai
pas été rappelé pour pour la suite parce
que c'est pas le projet de de cette
chaîne c'est à chaque chaque saison de
nouveaux intervenants
après bon c'est un projet qui t'ont
connais moi je connais pas la finalité
s'ils meurent demandait de participer
oui bien sûr je participerai c'était
c'était un travail qui était comédien
n'inquiétait pas facile parce qu' il
fallait écrire avec les autres dans des
disciplines qu'on choisit pas forcément
parce que j'ai pas choisi les gens avec
qui j'ai intervenait je serais content
d'intervenir avec toutes ces personnes
mais ça allait pas forcément ce serait
pas venue de moi quoi alors
il ya déjà des questions sur la
projection va écouter on va on va
commencer par ça parce que bah j'ai eu
la confirmation aujourd'hui donc ça
tombe très bien la projection de la
première projection elle aura lieu le 30
septembre à lyon
à l'endroit où je travaille depuis un an
qui est donc une résidence d'artistes
c'est au fort superpositions donc c'est
un immense bâtiment militaire qui a été
récupéré par par la municipalité pardon
qui se trouve dans le quartier de croix
rousse et donc c'est vraiment un immense
bâtiment on est plus de 40 artistes à
à occuper les lieux et cette soirée elle
va marquer en plus la fin de cette
résidence parce que juste après la
soirée à début octobre
on quitte les lieux c'est bouygues
telecom qui rachète le bâtiment et qui
nous et qui nous ont fait partir voilà
mais on ira ailleurs ça ira donc c'est
un bâtiment qui est magnifique qui a une
mg en une immense terrasse avec une vue
sur toute la ville et donc la projection
ça se passera en sous-sol dans les caves
de ceux de ce bâtiment qui sont des
grandes salles voûtées tout en pierre il
ya une jauge de d'environ 50 personnes
et non pas je vous lise en même temps
quand je parle sinon on n'a jamais s'en
sortir je rattraperai après est donc
cette projection elle est évidemment
commandeur gratuite pour les
participants de la campagne ulule pour
les autres allaient ouverte au grand
public
il y aura juste là les indiens le prix
d'entrée
c'est le prix pour payer superposition
qui est donc une association et qui nous
et qui nous accueille et je crois que ça
c'est un ca s'élève à 4,5 euros c'est
pas grand chose c'est juste pour pour
adhérer à l'association
et moi je fais pas payer le jeu fait pas
payer la soirée voilà donc ce sera
j'essaye de vous préparer une belle
soirée avec donc projection à peu près
une heure de projection ensuite
rencontre avec toute l'équipe donc lucas
pacotte mon co auteur l'illustrateur
christophe fournier le compositeur du
yunnan mayer donc c'est son nom
d'artiste ça peut être thomas regnault
vous pouvez d'ailleurs écouter ses
compositions sur youtube
et voilà et peut-être des surprises
je suis en train de penser à comment
vous faire une super soirée pour ça donc
c'est à lyon 30 septembre
l'horaire gelé pas encore par contre
j'ai préparé un mini formulaire pour
ceux qui voudraient déjà s'inscrire
parce que la jauge pour l'instant c'est
50 personnes c'est là là
à jauge de la salle donc je vais vous le
mettre en lien vous avez juste à mettre
votre nom votre prénom un contact mail
ou téléphone que j'ai une idée à peu
près de combien de personnes ici dans ce
live souhaiteraient venir à cette
projection
alors pareil je ne sais pas si ce
formulaire va marcher
si ça se trouve ça va être comme le live
numéro un
vous me direz si vous arrivez à le
système fonctionne j'ai jamais fait ça
de ma vie est donc cette soirée de
projection je vous donnerai la jeu tout
l'été je vais je vais communiquer sur
cette soirée
donc c'est à lyon c'est dans le quartier
croix rousse c'est accessible par métro
sur place il ya de quoi se restaurer à
il ya à manger et à boire il ya un bar
sur place
voilà donc que les lyonnais évidemment
c'est plus facile pour eux ceux qui sont
dans cette région dans le rhône aussi
c'est pas très compliqué de venir pour
les autres bas pour tous les laisse
outre même temps pour une fois qu'ils
abordent ce qui se passe à paris je veux
pas dire mais c'est c'est c'est pas mal
moi j'aimerais bien tout l'hiver faire
un espèce de tour de france pour
projeter cette série en donc avec ce
format non coupé formats longs avec à
chaque fois des bas dire que je viens je
serai présente à toutes les projections
et on pourrait on pourrait se rencontrer
discuter répondre à toutes les questions
il ya plein plein de choses à dire sur
la mythologie sur ce format documentaire
un peu road trip donc là bas je fais
appel à vous si vous avez envie que je
vienne
là vous vivez donc ça peut être paris
mais toutes les autres villes en fait
strasbourg orléans poitiers limoges
en fait il faut juste la simple chose si
vous pouvez m'aider c'est si vous
connaissez des salles des associations
qui ont une capacité d'accueil et à des
tarifs
on nous dira pas trop trop excessif et
bien envoyez moi un mail à mon mail
c'est toujours le même ou à un message
privé et on essaie d'organiser ça on est
je vous mets mon mail pro là c'est ça
mon mail pro ouais c'est ça claque
bonjour j'ai des rêves chantera tout
loupé attendait que c'est alors est-ce
que attache cliquer sur mon lien voir
s'il marche ça a l'air de marcher
oui donc pour ceux pour les lyonnais oui
le fort le fort quand je dis force et fo
rte c'est le bâtiment où on est c'est à
côté sur la place bellevue qui porte
bien son nom vous avez une vue sur le
rhône tout le tout lyon c'est
normalement le 30 septembre devrait
encore pouvoir profiter de de
l'extérieur il ya une demande d'accès
sur mon formulaire non alors attendez
attendez ça c'est pas compliqué comment
je sais pas je ne sais pas comment fait
il ne marche que pour toi mais j'ai
compris j'ai compris j'ai compris à
obtenir le nul alors attaque
e
[Musique]
je sais pas j'ai fait obtenir le lien je
ne sais pas si ça marche ou si c'est
toujours la même chose reste que google
docs les milliards d'autres veulent pas
renoncer
j'ai pas des milliards d'êtres couvert
mais je vais essayer de louis ali je
sais je sais monter un projet en grèce
administratif et financement et
compagnie mais par contre je sais pas
faire si je sais faire un google docs
partager mes mais là je n'y arrive plus
je n'y arrive plus
[Musique]
alors je vais y arriver non partagé à
c'est ça qu'on veut
alors
obtenir le lien
ça marche à oufa ok bon ben voilà ça
c'est fait up impeccable maintenant
merci merci
punaise de cette hyper efficace pour
maintenant j'essaie de remonter vos
questions comptes tu faire une suite au
projet odyssée jérôme du bien aidé à
finir celui-là
alors la suite de l'odyssée même si là
pour moi c'est un peu je n'ai pas fini
donc imaginer la suite c'est un peu
c'est un peu prématuré mais oui il ya
plusieurs idées qui se bousculent un peu
dans ma tête
voilà qui aurait l'idée ça c'est pas moi
qui les ai eus c'est une maison
d'édition d'une adaptation en livre une
adaptation étoffé donc je réfléchis à ce
projet de faire voilà une sorte de livre
sur la mythologie qui ne soit qu il soit
1 entre eux deux c'est à dire ni pour ce
conte habitude de voir pour les enfants
pour les ados c'est souvent là beaucoup
beaucoup de livres pour pour ce public
là où carrément l'extrême qui est
universitaire scientifique et pas
forcément qu'on peut pas lire à
n'importe quel moment
j'aimerais bien faire voilà un format
vulgariser
mais là la question se pose de la forme
est ce qu'il faut faire un format
catalogue qui est un peu site par site
ce que moi je trouve profondément chiant
mais qui est facile à écrire et c'est
pour ça que souvent les propositions des
éditeurs tendent vers ce vers ce format
il ya là la possibilité d'un carnet de
voyage merl à sa demande d'aidé des
commandes il faut être écrivain pour
bien écrire pour que ce soit pas naïfs
ou alors foire beaucoup beaucoup voyagé
et être beaucoup plus vieux pour que ça
passe pourquoi pas des formats scolaire
le nom de geneviève
bah oui après je sais que cette série a
beaucoup intéressé les enseignants en
histoire en français notamment notamment
l'épisode de santorin pour
l'interprétation d'une minute pour
pouvoir parler de platon voilà ça c'est
un projet ensuite faire une suite en
documentaire je pense pas parce que pour
le coup quand il a fallu choisir les
sites au moment enfin là quand j'étais à
lyon bien avant de partir il a fallu se
dire bon bah où est-ce qu'on part et
pourquoi on fait on fait ce parcours
plutôt qu'un autre est en fait j'avais
pas tant de possibilités parce qu'il
faille trouver à la fois des sites où il
ya des choses à montrer des choses
visuelles vraiment du vestige est un
mythe associé et les deux bas trouver
les deux c'est pas évident alors
par exemple là je vais vous dire deux
endroits qui sont associés à la
mythologie mais où il n'a pas sedrine et
où je ne suis pas allé et donc on n'ira
pas voilà les trois prochains épisodes
ne se passeront pas là c'est 3 et
ithaque taxe est là où il ya eu censé
être le palais du lycée il ya des
vestiges à trois aussi à des vestiges
mais c'est ça aurait été un peu au
niveau du documentaire j'aurai un peu
galéré à faire tout un épisode sur sur
ces lieux là voilà j'en ai déjà fait un
d'épisodes n'y a pas de vestiges c'était
le dernier
ça a été un challenge de reals de
réalisation après c'était très
intéressant parce que c'est le seul
épisode qui est comme ça et parce que il
associé à oedipe et oedipe bas il est
aveugle il aveugle il voit rien donc qui
est des vestiges ou pas c'est
intéressant d'un point de vue
cinématographique et je me suis amusé
aussi a commencé l'épisode dans la nuit
pour justement essayer de faire
comprendre aux spectateurs que on voit
pas grand chose voilà la vision et un
peu réduite
donc voilà la suite mais en tout cas ce
qui est sûr c'est que la fin d'avoir
préparé cette odyssée enfin tout ce
projet c'est deux ans de ma vie
pour la 7 séries sama j'ai pris
confiance en moi mais ça c'est surtout
grâce à vous parce que je pense que sans
la campanule j'aurais moins eu les
épaules pour tenir un tel projet tout
seul en tout cas à 4 est vraiment le vin
que vous en rendez pas compte mais
chaque message que vous m'écrivez je les
lis je les retiens une très bonne
mémoire de ce qu'on écrit ça me vraiment
ça c'est un moteur c'est vraiment du
fuel ou quoi c'est et
et ça m'a permis de me dire bah tournée
à l'étranger fin du documentaire être
toujours avec la caméra à la main et
improvisé a pas mises en scène je savais
juste où j'allais filmer pour les sites
et les musées mais le reste tout
l'habillage c'est c'est que je filme
tout le temps tout le temps tout le
temps eh ben ça c'est quelque chose que
j'ai adoré je pense que j'ai un peu
troué ma patte et donc le s'il y avait
une suite à l'odyssée haut niveau vidéo
ce serait peut-être pas en grèce mais
peut-être aller voir sur d'autres
continents
voilà peut-être faire une
comment pourrai-je j'ai pas une croisade
mais on va avoir une conquête c'est pas
à les voir aller voir d'autres pays ce
serait incroyable de faire ça dans
d'autres dans d'autres lieux alors je
vais remonter un peu ce que ce que vous
m'écrivez parce que sinon je loupe un
peu
est ce là saïga est ce la même
projection que celle des contreparties à
hull
oui oui c'est celle ci c'est la
projection promis qui n'a jamais pu
avoir lieu parce qu'on était en on est
toujours en crise sanitaire et l'aller
les salles de spectacles vont rouvrir à
la rentrée donc on peut voit la repenser
sa as-tu d'autres projets livre oui j'en
ai un mais j'ai pas de jets pas de deux
d'éditeur voilà pour l'instant
j'ai un autre projet qui en cours
d'écriture dont je n'ai parlé à personne
je n'ai pas pour présenter ce projet je
vais le faire à linverse pour l'instant
c'est des éditeurs qui sont venus vers
moi ce qui est une chance incroyable et
c'est très chouette
et là ça va plutôt être moi qui vais
présenter un manuscrit est allé taper
aux portes des éditeurs et ça ce sera
bas j'aimerais bien l'écrire a durant
cet hiver
voilà dans l'année mais donc ça sortira
inch insurance
c'est pas une comédie musicale
j'adore les comédies musicales si vous
saviez olala alors barré n'diaye on
refera des live un stade comme en avril
ah oui parce que certains d'entre vous
je ne sais pas combien on est ici on est
200 places est écrit en face de moi
pendant là les trois premières semaines
du confinement
gg on a fait des lives instagram tous
les matins avec le café
je faisais des lectures sur toute poésie
et c'était un super rendez vous matinal
moi j'ai adoré ça m'a un peu ça m'a fait
mal barré pay pay fallait parce que
c'était un moment dans le montage de
l'odyssée qui était crucial et j'ai bien
fait d'arrêter mais oui moi j'adorerais
pouvoir tenir un un moment de pas
forcément que de lecture mais de partage
voilà spontanée avec vous de pouvoir
échanger c'est quelque chose qui est
facile à faire sur instagram qui
pourrait aussi se faire sur youtube
mais bon vous avez vu comme jeu comme je
suis bi on like you tube
en fait c'est juste que ça ça ça demande
quand même du temps voilà pour ces lives
on a fait trois semaines de live tous
les matins parce je consacrais tous les
matins et
bon je peux pas dire que ça empiète pas
sur le reste
mais bon je prévois quand même de me
faire un petit moment de vacances après
la sortie de l'odyssée j'en ai vraiment
besoin parce que sinon ça va être
vraiment vraiment fatigué donc peut-être
que je viendrais peut-être que je ferai
des live le matin tu parles on va voir
alors salut alors nelson
en ce moment je viens surtout pour faire
un commentaire à ce même question que je
voulais lâché depuis plusieurs mois sous
une des vidéos de la série odyssée mais
c'est tout simplement génial
or c'est gentil merci ben moi c'est
sympa je suis carrément contente d c'est
vrai que quand le l'épisode 1 et le 2
surtout sont sortis mais un espèce de
soulagement parce que je savais que
cette série que je proposais avait
peut-être un style narratif qui est pas
forcément hyper en vogue sur youtube
après c'est quelque chose que qui moi me
plaît et je pars du principe que si on
fait quelque chose d'abord qui nous
plaît c'est dans lequel on croit bas les
autres y croirons forcément plus
facilement et j'avais vraiment envie de
proposer un format de vulgarisation
scientifique qui tape un peu moins dans
le la science c'est fun quelque chose
que j'ai pu faire et que j'aime bien
faire et regarder notamment que le
vortex était exactement ce style
narratif là et là j'avais envie voilà de
m'écouter un peu plus et d'être un peu
plus dans dans le poly dans le politique
pourquoi pas c'est un lapsus dans le
poétique dans la contemplation dans les
jeux de mots entre
ce qu'on voit à l'écran ce qui est écrit
voilà
alors et oui c'est vrai qu'en lisant le
commentaire pour que nos sauces et ted
et aide au site web mais santorin où il
ya justement des longue intro les longue
intro c'est c'est vraiment à l'opposé du
format youtube classique où on veut tout
de suite savoir à quelle sauce on va
être mangé il n'y a pas de temps à
perdre
la voilà c'était vraiment un mois je me
suis dit voilà je me suis écouté à 100%
j'ai fait quelque chose qui me plaisait
c'était purement égoïste comme comme
intro et visiblement ça vous a plu
donc c'est c'est hyper encourageant
vraiment pour moi après je vous ferai
pas toujours des magasins trop mais
c'est quoi l'argent là qui tombe 10
euros vous pouvez mp je sais pas c'est
quoi bah je sais pas ce que c'est xavier
merci xavier enfin je sais pas c'est un
don c'est quoi les jeux ça fait
longtemps que j'ai pas alors à temps
bonsoir storm cros salut bonne laisse
bonasse archéologie jennifer kerner que
tout le monde connaît au triste qu
actrice de retournac palio oui c'est un
don bah ma foi non c'est vraiment très
gentil je ne sais pas comment s'est
activée alors
bon vous avez l'air plutôt partant pour
une odyssée autres parcs en glace il y
aurait quoi comme comme continent qui
vous plairait je promets rien alors
ligne qui an'a jones
certes le format n'est pas youtube est
ce que mais n'oublie pas que tu n'as
vise que tu ne vis pas le public
majoritaire youtube certes c'est
j'attendrai la fin de l'odyssée et puis
les projections mais oui c'est vrai que
ce sont des vidéos qui font pas beaucoup
de vues elles font elles font les débuts
à peu près similaire à ce qu'il ya sur
la chaîne
mais quand on compare avec le reste de
la visualisation scientifique
donc voilà des copains des collègues on
pourrait s'attendre un thème comme la
mythologie à ce que ça ça décolle
beaucoup plus donc ça c'est assez un peu
un deuil que j'ai fait fin tout cas pour
youtube et c'est pour ça que j'ai envie
de développer des projections grand
public pourra les bains toucher un autre
public que youtube qui je sais que c'est
je suis sur un espèce de sas et la
frontière c'est la frontière entre un
format court qui est accessible parce
que c'est disponible en un clic et que
quand même la chaîne à quelques années
et avec eux il ya une certaine
communauté quand on est assez nombreux
je crois qu'on est presque 80 milles
maintenant ce qui est c'est trop bien
mais voilà les vidéos là elles font
elles font pas font pas assez de vue à
mon goût ça c'est sûr donc il faut les
il faut les partager évidemment il
fallait partager rien d'autre à faire la
télé la télé ouais bah la télé la télé
je ne sais pas je sais pas où aller la
télé asie mineure
yes un axe central ah bah oui évidemment
non mais oui oui mais oui moi si je vous
si je pouvais faire un petit petit
conquête aller au mexique retourner au
mexique
j'ai eu la chance de pouvoir faire un
voyage au mexique c'était le plus beau
voyage de
de toute ma vie bon allez c'est court
temps je n'ai eu que 30 ans cette année
mais bon ouais amérique latine ok ok bon
on a à peu près sur la même longueur
d'onde inde
ouais inde ouais ouais ouais théologie
japonaise égyptienne
oui évidemment les gîtes est ce qu on
pourrait avoir des sous titres en
anglais
abarca j'adorerais sous titrée cette
série en anglais en espagnol
donc c'est quelque chose que j'ai en
tête et sur lequel je vais travailler
parce que moi qui vais faire les sous
titres j'en suis pas capable mais mais
pour l'instant j'ai tellement de choses
à gérer que je peux pas m'en occuper
mais il faut absolument que que qui est
des sous titres ça c'est sûr donc si
vous vous y connaissez si vous êtes vous
même traducteur qui vous avez l'habitude
de ça ou que vous connaissez des gens
qui sont capables de le faire
envoyez moi mes jeunes viennent je sais
envoyez-moi les contacts écrivez moi je
cherche aussi en fait de la chute dans
une période où je cherche aussi à
renflouer les caisses parce que bah
c'est un projet où je suis productrice
vous aussi voilà vous êtes producteur à
hauteur de 9000 euros
si je me souviens bien mais j'ai mis
beaucoup beaucoup d'argent personnel là
dedans et donc évidemment s'il ya une
semaine un sous titrage je sais que les
sous titres parfois c'est la communauté
qu'il fait à titre bénévole et c'est
génial
moi je sujet du mal à demander ça la
pression me le propose je dirais pas non
mais c'est quelque chose que je pourrais
peut-être un terme pays mais bon je sais
pas combien ça coûte
voilà donc si vous vous y connaissez là
dedans envoyez-moi des infos une odyssée
sous marine
ah bah oui d'ailleurs il ya un très très
beau projet dont vous avez peut-être
entendu parler qui est fait par théo
drieu et les abello théorie yeux c'est
sa chaîne ces balades mental
et les abbés l'eau c'est ça qui tient
est de sciences la chaîne du cnrs ils
ont fait une super campagne hull ou qui
est en jeu c'est plus de financement
participatif pour une série de vidéos
qui est tourné sous l'eau donc c'est
génial c'est donc une cei sur la
biodiversité marine voilà cette super
merci pour tous vos dons merci oise à
man voilà la foule sera donc vite les 8
bits
merci san à 33 16
c'est trop gentil alors les prémices de
l'humanité en afrique oui l'afrique ce
serait incroyable d'aller en afrique je
sais vraiment une destination vers
laquelle j'ai envie d'aller
j'aimerais beaucoup aller en ethiopie
notamment voir les les constructions en
terre ça m'intéresse beaucoup
voilà
je vais anniversaire merci odyssée en
polynésie oui non mais oui on peut à
chaque fois c'est jamais descoings
dégueulasse 1 c'est ya pas de nice et en
angleterre alors cafouille est mon soir
que le ty j'adorais cette odyssée abbas
est pas une c'est pas une question ça
c'est un gentil très très très gentil
commentaires merci c'est gentil je te
suivrai partout où tu nous emmènera pour
une nouvelle saison
bon la lorraine une odyssée en lorraine
mais attention je la gd pas je ne vais
pas faire une nouvelle odyssée tout de
suite même même l'année prochaine ces
noms là il faut que je faut que je me
repose et que je repose mon compte
bancaire parce que de faire un tournage
à l'étranger
évidemment c'est c'est cher vous avez
suivi l'histoire de des autorisations de
tournage des textes de tournage
notamment avec ce conte pas suivi quand
même j'ai une anecdote croustillante le
pour le tournage d'athènes dans le musée
le nouveau musée de l'acropole donc
l'acropolis museum
on m'a demandé trois jours avant de
tourner alors que j'avais déjà payé la
taxe est signé quoi les autorisations de
tournage m'a demandé d'une taxe
supplémentaire de 72 mille euros voilà
c'était en fait tant d'euros par seconde
de film et donc j'ai failli j'ai ma
réaction ça a été gt1 santorin
quand j'ai appris ça j'avais fini un
tournage et j'étais tout seul le début
de la série de les tourner tout tout
seul
vraiment moi et mon sac à dos et donc
j'étais un peu caution pour moi même
pour tous j'étais évidemment stressé
mais j'avais un peu la tête dans le
guidon donc j'avais plein de choses à
penser
et j'avais bien organisé le tournage
pour que ça se passe
un essai campsas est tombée trois jours
avant de tourner à athènes j'ai un peu
j'ai un peu déprimé enfin je sais pas si
tu es c'était dur à gérer
et du coup j'ai écrit à l'acropole au
musée de l'acropole j'en ai dit ben vous
doutez bien que j'ai pas 72 mille euros
disponible là en trois jours en plus
c'est une [ __ ] de cible et des coups
bas en leur écrivant j'ai failli ne pas
leur écrire le mail je me dis alors
quand même tu leur dire que j'annule je
n'ai pas écouté je peux pas venir
j'ai pas les sous je suis en auto
production génère tout seul je ne vais
pas du tout ce budget et le lendemain
ils m'ont dit ah bah vous êtes en
autoproduction banon mais vous payez pas
à la grecque quoi le truc fort à la
grecque à la méditerranée voilà tel
qu'il faut il faut toujours maintenir le
dialogue c'est ce que j'ai retenu et ça
m'a beaucoup servi pour ce tournage dès
qu'on vous dit non pour tenter de
négocier faut boire un café frappé faut
boire un jus d'orange et ça passe
alors l'escargot il faut vraiment avoir
des sous titres aussi en français il ya
des sous titres en français
il faut en plus c'est moi qui les écrit
donc c'est mon texte
normalement il n'y a pas de fautes
d'orthographe tout et tout est nickel
chrome
il faut juste activé sur youtube ils
sont pas natifs
ils le seront peut-être pour la
projection
je ne sais pas peut-être pas donc voilà
merci jonathan merci merci c'est très
très gentil c'est pas dégueu
l'angleterre non mais je n'en retire
j'ai vécu un an j'ai vécu un an à
londres
moi je suis plus latine que que qu'autre
chose donc je vois là je préfère aller
en italie qu'à londres à rome qu'à
londres
mais non mais j'ai eu il ya des très
très beaucoup et notamment toute la côte
ouest est incroyable quels sont tes
apport financier de vulgarisatrice j'ai
plein plein de sources de revenus qui se
cumulent des petites sources il ya
évidemment vos la communauté donc tipi
ulule enfin ulule ça c'est non tipi liu
type levin et les vidéos sont monétiser
ça rapporte un petit peu d'argent c'est
c'est pas grand chose
ça dépend là pour la série c'est c'est
plus intéressant j'ai touche aussi les
droits d'auteur notamment via youtube
ces terres que depuis trois ans des
sociétés d'auteurs donc c'est par
exemple à l'as cannes où la hesse a cédé
cdi qui valent en de la sacem assas m6
pour la musique viennent ont tapé à la
porte de youtube en leur disant à
écouter vous vous générez beaucoup
d'argent grâce aux créateurs et vous ne
leur reverser absolument rien la seule
chose qui est reversé c'est l'argent des
annonceurs des publicitaires mais
youtube en tant que telle ne reversent
rien alors que sans la création
il n'existe pas donc c'est un peu le
même système que la redevance télé les
sociétés d'auteurs et l'état français a
dit à youtube nous maintenant nous
fonctionnons une partie de vos revenus
et nous leur versons à la création et
donc bah on touche on touche alors c'est
je le sais parce que j'ai regardé
aujourd'hui en moyenne on touche 37
centimes
toutes les 1000 vue de droits d'auteur
ça fait pas large mais voilà c'est ça et
ensuite bah moi je fonctionne je
fonctionne aussi avec les bourses à la
création du cnc
j'y ai droit est donc là bas j'ai pu en
avoir une pour l'odyssée à hauteur de
10000 euros
la série a coûté 24 mille francs que je
refasse faut que je refasse les comptes
précis voilà et donc là le cnc ça permet
aussi de ceux de se payer un petit peu
là pour l'odyssée moi j'ai surtout payer
les gens qui m'entouraient c'était
vraiment un travail dès le départ je
sais que c'est un travail
d'investissement il fallait que je
montre ce dont j'étais capable
et voilà pour les futurs projets je
m'autoriserai à me payer correctement
évidemment alors
tu es doctorante en histoire non je ne
suis pas doctorante j'ai un master 1
master recherche
j'ai fait un an de préparation de thèse
donc j'ai cherché des bourses
j'ai l'impression que ma vie c'est
chercher des bourses mais bon ça la
recherche ou à la création est en fait
l'année de préparation de thèse ou j'ai
soumis mon projet de thèse j'ai lancé ma
chaîne youtube et j'ai arrêté j'ai
arrêté la thèse et je regrette pas ça
veut pas dire que j'aimerais pas faire
une thèse devrait faire une thèse mais
mais peut-être pas en archéologie parce
qu'une thèse en archéologie ses études
et du matériel sert des caisses remplies
bas de tesson ou pas pour voler bas pour
moi c'était des tessons de poterie et
jeu au bout de deux ans de tessons de
poterie j'en avais un petit peu marre
donc et rendez vous il ya plein de
questions malberg comme dirait un ancien
grec arrêtons de parler d'argent par le
talent pourquoi pas ouais on va arrêter
de parler d'argent on a commencé à
parler un peu plus de la série un peu
d'art qui est quand même là j'étais
stressé avant cela est vrai ou la vache
c'est quoi la chronologie de la culture
mycénienne mince je sais plus
aa alors appelle moi je dit hier je suis
nouveau est ce que quelqu'un peut
m'expliquer sur quoi et orienter la
chaîne la chaîne est une et une chaîne
spécialisée en archéologie anthropologie
histoire voilà sciences humaines et
sociales
de manière générale pourquoi tu as
commencé la poterie alors j'ai étudié
les tessons de céramique je fais pas de
poterie et je suis pas non plus
spécialiste de la céramique
mais je les études et parce qu en fait
j'étais je me suis spécialisé sur la
navigation antiques et j'essayais de
comprendre comment les marins vivait à
bord des navires
sous l'antiquité romaine donc vraiment
notre bassin méditerranéen notamment je
faisais pas mal de recherches sur les
épaves autour de narbonne de marseille
toute la côte est de l'espagne en
pourias ce genre de coin et je
m'intéressais à la vaisselle de bord
c'est-à-dire les assiettes les gobelets
des marins sur lequel souvent ils
inscrivent leur nom et j'essaye voilà de
savoir qu'est-ce qui a été utilisé par
l'équipage
et qu'est-ce qui a été utilisée pour le
commerce est pas confondre les choses et
essayer de retracer le trajet du bateau
voilà c'était ça mon travail alors
l'escargot oui d'ailleurs l'escargot
faucon cause moment mais justement
j'imagine que certains commentaires
peuvent être difficile quand on a passé
des mois années sur un projet donc pour
remettre donc la dernière vidéo est une
vidéo qui parle donc du voyage de deep
et oedipe donc passe donc à thèbes peps
et en béotie c'est au centre un petit
peu de la grèce et c'est une ville où et
n'a quasiment aucun vestige
archéologique
et donc à la fin de cette vidéo c'est
vrai il ya une une séquence qui est pas
facile à regarder et et certains d'entre
vous l'ont dit ils ont pointé et vous
avez raison de le dire notamment
d'escargots qui m'a laissé un
commentaire qui est intéressant que j'ai
relu cet après-midi tranquillement et je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec avec ce
que tu ce que tu m'a écrit donc c'est
une séquence où donc on voit un un homme
c'est pas un boucher c'est une séquence
que j'ai tourné dans une taverne jeu en
fait on s'arrêtait sur le bord de la
route pour boire un café et c'est en
train de préparer un méchoui pour pour
un mariage qui avait lieu à midi et moi
c'est des choses qui m'intéressent jeu
j'ai besoin voire comprendre comment on
fait et donc j'ai demandé à ce monsieur
qui tenait le café et qui était aussi un
éleveur qui avait son ses moutons si je
pouvais film et il était carrément
content voilà c'est un moment d'échangé
ça a été un bon moment du voyage et donc
c'est vrai c'est un agneau qui est
dépassé au moment où le voit dans la
vidéo qui appuient la peau et il va être
mis sur le pic
donc c'est une image qui est inattendu
c'est vrai elle arrive on s'y attend pas
même si j'ai fait exprès de mettre une
image avant des halles d'athènes les
halles d'athènes donc cessons des
grandes halles on vend du poisson de la
viande parce qu'en grèce on mange
beaucoup de viande à la retraite c'est
très très lié à leur culture et donc
c'est vrai qu'on m'a reproché de ne pas
avoir
très pas annoncé cette séquence qui est
pas facile à regarder
je dirais pas qu'elle est choquante
parce que parce que c'est pas une cenne
d'abattoirs c'est pas une scène où il ya
du sang qui coule à foison c'est du
documentaire donc on peut s'attendre à
avoir des choses de la vie réelle et la
vie réelle ce parent passait pas que des
choses agréables
voilà il ya un peu de tout et surtout
dans du format documentaire où il ya une
grande part d'improvisation
donc c'est une séquence que j'ai à quel
j'ai tenu parce que tout l'épisode parle
du sacrifice du sacrifice de dip mais
aussi je le dis en intro jeudi oedipe
c'est une figure christique ccc le
christ avant l'heure et on peut même se
dire que la jésus est un et 1 le dip
moderne et cet agneau balagne haut c'est
aussi ça représente jésus le c'est très
symbolique quand il est en fourche et
sur le sur le pic métalliques
ça représente aussi la croix donc c'est
pour ça que j'ai mis aussi en conclut il
y avait tout un tout un parallèle que
moi j'ai vu qui évidemment je le
comprends ne se voit pas forcément aux
premières au premier à la pro premier
visionnage et ensuite ça je lave rouge
enfin je le jeu qu'on soit 7,8 cette
image n'est pas facile à voir parce que
moi-même bas en la montant non pas en
longtemps je me souviens de ma première
demande comment ma première impression
une scène j'étais un peu crispé et et
notamment je sais que j'ai baissé le son
moment où la peau est transpercé parce
qu'il ya le son de la peau transpercer
et gelé baissé parce que moi ça me
gênait parce que je suis plus habitué à
avoir des bêtes en pas les jeux l'été
j'ai grandi à la campagne j'avais des
animaux ont tué les lapins voilà ça y
est j'ai été habitué à ça je l' ai perdu
cette habitude
tant mieux
mais je sais ce que c'est d'être
sensible aux images et mais pour autant
j'ai pas trop hésité à la montre et
parce que je me cette série aussi elle
combat un peu une idée des mythes qui
seraient des histoires pour s'endormir
comme un peu les contes de perrault
alors que quand on rentre dans ces
histoires on se rend compte que c'est
glauque
les contes les mythes c'est glauque et
ça s'adresse pas que aux enfants il ya
plusieurs niveaux de lecture et les miz
on parle de la mort c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment le fil rouge de des histoires
donc il a abandonné
l'épisode iv c'est le milieu de la série
il fallait que que je montre un petit
peu quelque chose de 2,2 morbide
voilà sans être gore on n'est pas dans
un c'est pas un abattage la bête est
déjà morte
on a déjà parlé de sacrifices humains
avec avec une hausse est d'ailleurs là
avec l'illustrateur on a fait le choix
de montrer les images les premières
images de cet épisode numéro un
elles sont pas tendres il ya un
minotaure qu'à la tête coupée donc c'est
pas forcément agréable en soit après
c'est du dessin donc c'est plus facile à
regarder
et puis la mythologie c'est vraiment il
ya vraiment une grande part de 2 et de
morbidité enfin quand on pense à au
retour d'ulysse avant qu'ils arrivent à
ithaque
itunes est quand même une scène de
massacre énorme
oui tu tous les prétendants de pénélope
et il ya du détail dans dans le texte un
c on coupe les têtes on les transperce
donc voilà je sais avec ma réaction
dans les commentaires j'étais un petit
peu un petit peu étonné de la vivacité
de certains commentaires qui était un
peu qu'ils disaient choqués et être
choqué par ça je suis pas sûr que ce
soit le mot propre on peut être déranger
on peut être sensible au moins dire je
suis sensible ça me fait quelque chose
évidemment mais je souhaite à tout le
monde d'être un peu sensible face à ces
images mais c'est le seul réel et puis
on fait pas du n'est pas de la pub ans
que je fais alors je vais
ah oui et pour finir sur thèbes
alors là j'ai besoin de vous beaucoup de
gens m'ont dit avoir un problème avec la
hauteur le niveau du son de la musique
moi je ne l'est pas dans mes écouteurs
dans mon casque
mais je vous crois si vous le dit c'est
que c'est vrai et j'ai du mal à savoir
où est ce que ça se joue dans le montage
est ce que c'est la musique de début qui
est trop forte
dans ce cas là je la baisse de quelques
décibels mais mais comme c'est à peu
près les mêmes niveaux que pour les
autres épisodes
voilà près faut parfois ça se joue à
trois décibels et c'est trop fort et je
l'entends tu sais moi je suis hyper
sensible des oreilles ça m'énerve mais
d'accord c'est ok c'est les musiques de
début est un jeu de noter parce que il
faut que je le corrige pas ce que c'est
c'est dommage d'accord c'est vraiment
celle du début en fait c'est la même
musique
les épisodes sont toujours construits
pareil la musique d'intro vous la
retrouvez à la fin comme ça vous savez à
peu près quand on arrive à la conclusion
je fais tout en douceur je vous préviens
tout est pensé c'est la musique d'intro
ok ok moi un petit coup
ok alors je remonte un petit peu vos
commentaires les mythes gréco alors stop
cros y aux romains ne sont pas neutres
et qu'avoir l'histoire de daphné et le
cycle des atrides c'est pas joyeux mais
oui c'est rarement joyeux mais c'est ce
qui en fait tout tout l'intérêt alors
merci martin voilà il ya des gens qui
font des dons c'est trop sympa merci
merci beaucoup
il n'y a pas trop de questions c'est
plus des des retours est-ce que les
vieilles séries jean la modernité vont
reprendre à foug louis oui je pense
alors le ce qui va se passer
donc là on a une date butoir un petit
peu c'est 30 septembre c'est un peu le
d'ailleurs pour ceux qui ne pourront pas
venir à cette projection et vous êtes
nombreux évidemment et qui ont donné à
la campagne en fait tous les gens sur
ulule tipi your type et des gens pour
septembre de l'ue les tipis je vous
enverrai le lien un lien privé pour
visionner cette vidéo en intégrale je
vais pas la mettre tout de suite sur
youtube
je ne sais pas trop comment ça je vais
le faire parce qu'il faut le jeu
rebeille des droits d'auteur enfin des
droits oui d'exploitation pour des
musiques ça coûte très cher donc c'est
plus facile de le faire en projection où
on les en priver et voilà et donc après
cette cette date du 30 septembre
vous aurez sur la chaîne des vidéos de
commandes voit la cdc des projets donc
de de commandes qui pourront peut-être
s'insérer dans la modernité je les ai
pas encore écrite donc je ne sais pas
dans quelle émission elles vont
s'insérer et ensuite eh ben il y aura un
très très gros projet pour 2021
voilà et ça je peux pas vous en dire
plus mais il y aura là je suis en train
de de préparer un moyen métrage et je
recherche évidemment des financements
voilà je vais demander le cnc je vais
demander de l'argent à la région voilà
je suis en train de chercher ça donc
vous aurez des vidéos un peu moins entre
l'odyssée et ce projet secret vous aurez
des vidéos un peu plus classique
peut-être dû face caméra des choses qui
me demande un petit peu moins de 2 de
travail de montage et réalisation
donc c'est sympa aussi parce caméra
parce que vous ne voyez pas vous voyez
pas souvent
et voilà et après 2021 tu parles alors
ta fixe est trop long tu parlais plus
tôt des projections à des productions
dans différentes villes de france est
envisageable pour toi et ton équipe de
faire ça en belgique
oui tout à fait tout à fait d'ailleurs
j'étais à bruxelles le week-end dernier
donc voyez je peux revenir à bruxelles
avait pas de problème ou ailleurs en
belgique mais peut-être plus tôt
bruxelles tendance à un partenariat avec
les boucheries charal aaa
enfin ça dépend ce tout une question de
business is business
non non non quand même ya des priorités
alors
où
alors l'escargot sd nature est un mythe
que de l'adapter aux moeurs actuelles
bon pour ma part c'est un peu le cas
pour pour au dip
en tout cas pour la psychanalyse c'est
la proche psychanalytique mais après
faut pas essentialiser les psys sont au
courant que le dip du 5e siècle avant
n'est pas le même que le nôtre et est en
fait c'est toujours ça la mythologie ou
les comptes il faut il faut il faut en
connaître les origines et savoir bas ce
qu'on leur doit
mais mais ne pas évidemment calquer nos
moeurs sur celle des populations
anciennes parce que là on se trompe
ça porte un nom d'ailleurs s'appelle de
l'éphémère isme je peux vous l'écrire
mais j'ai peut-être le pvc plus gros
secret bien à chaque pas c'est le mot
juste
as tu des zigzags via tu dessiné pendant
ton d'aunis et moi non par contre mon
lucas pacotte qui était donc la personne
qui m'accompagnait sur le tournage à
partir d'athènes a tenu un carnet de
croquis qui était super et d'ailleurs
c'était un objet qui était très très qui
est très important dans ce tournage
parce que on a eu beaucoup
d'interactions grâce à grâce à ce carnet
de croquis c'est à dire que beaucoup de
grecs sont venus nous voir parce qu'il
voyait qu'on filmer et qu'on destinait
et donc il ya des discussions
évidemment qu'ils qui ont démarré de la
et de ces discussions battaient les
abats faut absolument que vous alliez
film et tell tale coincé pas connu vous
serez tranquille il y aura un beau point
de vue il ya plein de choses comme ça
qui ont qui qui sont nées des dessins
c'est hyperimportant j'aimerais beaucoup
dessiner mais je n'ai
pas eu ce don là à la naissance et je
n'ai pas travaillé de toute façon
et quelqu'un qui était au tu m'as déjà
appris ce mot l'an dernier au frames
oui mais dernière au festival de france
j'avais fait une conférence sur centaure
et donc j'avais appris sans fin dit ce
mot oui à ou à zaman pardon tu ne
réponds pas à tommy boy et - pardon j'ai
du mal à tout suivre battu faire un
épisode une série sur l' empire romain
pas tout de suite je veux en fait j'en
ai tellement mou fait à la fac et pour
le masters que j'ai pas envie d'y
retourner pour l'instant c'est pas c'est
pas un univers qui me avec lequel je
suis très à l'aise et je suis pas très
talentueuse paraît qu'il ya quand même
des voilà au bout d'un moment quand on a
étudié qu'on a travaillé sur un sujet on
peut en connaître les bases mais de là à
réussir à le faire vivre
notamment auprès d'un du grand public
c'est autre chose
bien que moi l empire romain
on va pas ensemble quoi c'est pas c'est
pas hyper évident mais bon voilà je
pourquoi pas je suis pas j'ai pas fermée
mais c'est pas c'est pas ce vers quoi
elle envie d'aller tout de suite après
si on sait pas si l'inrap arrive et
qu'il dise vous utile d'une petite série
en italie sur l' empire romain ou
ailleurs emmenez moi à narbonne tu le
ferais non mais c'est vrai que voilà et
puis toutes les fouilles que j'ai pu
faire en archéologie c'était toujours du
vestiges romains et c'était dur c'est
très dur à fouiller les sites romains
c'est forcément beaucoup de pioche
beaucoup de de vous des quais c'est quoi
vous enlever beaucoup de terre et les
niveaux d'élévation qui sont bas plus
important du coup j'en ai un souvenir
difficile alors alléluia est-ce que tu
essayer d'aligner les villes de
l'odyssée sur un équateur pencher qui
montrerait une procession des équinoxes
bah oui évidemment évidemment
alors je suis à bayard je veux pas être
prof à l'occasion avec ton master
d'histoire cherche parfois des
remplacements temporaires non bah moi je
fais youtube c'est déjà pas mal
non non je peux pas je suis je sais je
suis pas très bonne en histoire moi ce
jeu je fais un peu de la résistance à
l'idée de retenir les dates je
fonctionne pas comme ça donc tout ça
peut paraître complètement paradoxal
mais je m'estime très très mauvaises en
en histoire c'est alors qu'est ce qu'ils
attendent et je reprends mais j'ai des
petites notes préparer mon live feed car
on stresse et ça faisait trop longtemps
que j'étais pas apparus ici
est-ce qu'on serait pas un petit
concours un petit concours des familles
j'ai à vous faire gagner
alors certains d'entre vous l'auront les
auront déjà si c'est le cas j'ai fait
j'ai rien d'autre à vous offrira par des
non gérer un autre à vous offrir
je en jeu des lots c'est à dire que il y
aura six gagnants avec à chaque fois
c'est le même cadeau ce sera le pin's de
la série et la carte la carte
mythologique que vous connaissez qui se
déplie comme une carte ign com une carte
de rando avec de l'autre côté du texte
voilà et des illustrations toujours par
christophe fournier
ok vous avez l'air vous avez l'air prêt
bon c'est pas des questions hyper
difficile à faut juste avoir vu les
épisodes si vous n'avez pas vu ben tant
pis pour vous alors comment [ __ ] la
cia pas de modérateur
j'espère que que je ferais que je serai
juste voilà go go go on y va ok il ya
six questions si gagnant et il n'y a pas
d'ordre de faciliter ou difficulté y en
a qui sont plus faciles que d'autres
voilà le premier qui répond bas j'essaye
de le noter voilà j'espère qu'il y aura
pas de décalage
on y va première question c'est un nom
qu'on cherche
quel est le premier roi mythique
d'athènes
et essayer de ne pas faire trop de
fautes d'orthographe ça peut compter le
premier roi mythique d'athènes ça se
trouve elle y perdure cette question
robert non
punaise mince on commence par une
question trop dur oui la corde serpent
ses crocs isabelle pareil antilles bravo
bravo bien écrit parfait nickel alors
donc isabelle paré anti donc les alors
hop
ok on continue alors c'est crops ses
crocs oui c'est le premier roi d'athènes
c'est un gars qui est né mi homme mi
serpent
il est fils de gaia donc à la terre il
est il est élevé par athéna donc
peut-être que là il avait déjà dans la
poche athéna et c'est à thénac à gagner
à la fin et on dit que c'est le premier
roi de la ville parce qu'on lui donne
une fonction civilisatrice c'est lui qui
va créer athènes au sens de police
police à la cité voilà ouais il faut
avoir un peu un bac + 8
ben on met d'accord elles seront pas
tout de ce niveau alors mais franchement
vous tapez ses crocs vous allez voir
vous allez voir ce sa petite bouille
sympa tâche
c'est très bien bravo isabelle hallé
deuxième question
comment s'appelle l'archéologue qui a
fouillé qu'une hausse
gregor boyer ouais c evans on peut avoir
son prénom et nom c'est evans c'est
soeur arthur evans donc pardon grégoire
boyer bravo soeur arthur et [ __ ] je
suis en train d'écrire et grégoire evans
bien renvoyer oui evans il est né à la
moitié du 19e siècle et il a fouillé
cnossos en 1900 je crois bien commencé
en 1900 et en fait la particularité des
vans c'est pour ça qu'il s'est fait
connaître aussi bas que pour le site
qu'il a découvert c'est parce que il a
choisi de reconstituer le sit in situ
c'est à dire de ne pas décaler fin de le
remettre ça ne faisait pas du tout en
fait à l'époque et ça a même donné un
art mots alors attention après et
vérisme nous avons un nouveau mot le
fait de de reconstruire un site
archéologique sur le site archéologique
ça s'appelle je crois que c'est féminin
une anastylose anastylose on apprend des
mollahs aujourd'hui attention
sauf que je sais plus si c'est féminin
ou masculin je crois que c'est féminin
mais c'est peut-être un piège voilà
et donc à l'entrée de de knossos vous
avez une merveilleuse statue en bronze
de d'evans j'ai fait une crise dana
stylo de la semaine dernière c'est
féminin très bien
ok allez troisième question non non
c'est pas trop difficile quels sites
archéologiques a probablement inspiré à
platon le mythe de l'atlantide
ah mais je me le site je veux le nom du
site veut pas le nom de l'île c'est à
santorin oui mais c'est pas un site sans
toi pour que ce soit bien écrit
olalala le barbant une yourte ac
akrotiri bien orthographié c'est très
bien akrotiri le barbant ouhlala 20 8
bravo bravo bravo accroc tiré avec un
cas vous êtes plaint le savoir mais
c'est le barbant cas qu'il a acquis la
wii les eaux kim
ah ouais tu l'a écrit qu'un sait comment
faire bon allez à égalité n'est pas un
pin's et une carte prêts à aller je suis
sympa vois pas ma pas pourrir la soirée
vous aurez tous les deux lots ya pas de
problème on en rajoute un petit voilà
j'aime pas j'aime pas l'esprit de
compétition c'est pas mon truc je
déteste ça je déteste des tests donc
voilà je suis bonne foi oui rien alors
j'en suis donc clac clac clac wells en
tord à un terreau afin terrasse et là
c'est le sait sans toi c'est le nom de
l'île et c'est pas le nom du site
c'est comme si vous me disiez je pas
naples pour pompéi pas non ça va pas ça
va aller on accueille 1 1 2 3 4
quatrième question quel nom portait lé
palais entre guillemets crétois de l'âge
du bronze
normalement on a parlé enfin c'est pas
normalement je le sais c'est dans
l'épisode 1 le nom des palais crétois
les gros machins là pas aller à mes
garonne exactement
antonin kérébel parfait c'est précis
consignes synthétique
antonin tew kml pas les âmes et garonne
donc mais yaron sa venue c'est juste un
terme qui veut dire c'est au maire qui
l'utilisent je crois le premier ça veut
dire grande salle c'est vraiment les
images que vous voyez sur le sur
l'épisode de knossos le premier épisode
ces espèces de foyers fin de bâtiment
carré avec des colonnes voilà il ya
plusieurs là plusieurs tailles à une
entrée un vestibule et puis ensuite il
ya cette espèce de grande cour carrée à
ciel ouvert avec d une enfilade de
colonnes et jeu mais voilà le terme de
balle est entre guillemets parce que
pour nous pas laid ça renvoie à la
résidence des rois et visiblement enfin
c'est pas les dirigeants ne vivait pas
dans ces lieux là d'ailleurs ça c'est
quelque chose que c'est une précision
qu'il faudra apporter par rapport à ce
que je dis dans l'épisode 1 épisode 1 je
parle pas mal de la fonction religieuse
je dis aussi c'est des lieux qui sont
polyvalents en fait les lieux ces
bâtiments là ils ont plusieurs fonctions
et notamment en fait il faudrait presque
voir que nos sauces comme un centre un
institut genre une un mélange entre le
trésor public et la sécurité sociale
voyez c'est des gros bâtiment
administratif on a des administrations
assez lourde qui gère les stocks
agricoles les fonds les tablettes
d'argile avec l'écriture
voilà c'est vraiment des espèces de
centre en tout cas c'est ce que les
archéologues la recherche là ces
dernières années tend à montrer et pas
du tout de la résidence même pas de la
même pas des résidences de villégiature
donc voilà c'est quelque chose qu'il
faut avoir en tête pour l'archéologie
on essaye toujours c'est humain de fixer
une fonction pour un lieu pour un objet
et et le travail de l'archéologie
c'est de montrer que les objets pour les
périodes anciennes en tout cas les
objets et les lieux sont ce qu'on
appelle polysémique c'est à dire qu'ils
ont plusieurs sens ils ont plusieurs
fonctions sans aucune au contraire ils
en ont plusieurs
et qui se combine c'est vraiment l'idée
de la polyvalence quoi ethnos au sein
tous ces grands complexes moi j'ai
plutôt utilisé ce mot dans la vidéo
grand complexe la folie comprendre comme
des lieux qui encadrent enfin qui
regroupe le pouvoir économique politique
et religieux et c'est vraiment trois
choses qui sont indissociables qu'on ne
dissocie pas dans les partis soutiennent
le méga ministère
ouais mais c'est il ya vraiment ça
d'ailleurs si vous voulez si vous êtes
vraiment intéressé par l'archéologie des
périodes anciennes par la grèce bat de
l'âge du bronze donc c'est la
protohistoire la préhistoire il ya un
ouvrage que vous pouvez vous offrir mais
sait il est assis les chairs je vous le
dis il est cher mais c'est gelé je
l'aimé à côté de moi c'est vraiment une
une bible c'est vraiment la bible mais
c'est vulgariser c'est très très bien
vulgarisé vous vous comprendrez tout
s'est en plus serré sans sa sortie
l'année dernière c'est belin qui fait sa
sénescence de la grèce c'est dans
d'ailleurs dans toutes mes barre d'infos
je les mets en bibliographie
c'est c'est enfin si vous aimez l'art
qui est franchement offrez vous et
essayez de vous procurer ça coûte 49
euros c'est pour ça je vous dis il faut
être passionné faut pas si vous pouvez
aussi le prendre pour découvrir parce
que c'est une bonne manière de rentrer
dans le sujet donc il ya toute une
partie à la fin
petite partie quelques pages sur knossos
il ya un portrait de l'archéologue
arthur evans et il ya deux pages sur ce
qu'est un palais ce qu'est un mégaphone
qu'est ce que les archéologues en dise
aujourd'hui voilà et oui et toute la
collection de bellaing là c'est
incroyable ce qu'ils ont fait
franchement ils ont ils ont mis toutes
les autres éditions à terre pour la
grèce c'est fabuleux mais pour toute la
tende et j'ai posé mon ordi sur un autre
c'est celui de la mésopotamie et celui
qui est très très bien qu'il ait reçu
des prix c'est celui sur l'afrique qui a
été dirigée par françois xavier fauvel
hauteur de duos rhinocéros d'or voilà cd
cd livre référence si vous aimez
l'archéologie
allez-y vous serez pas déçus vraiment
vous serez pas déçus et puis y'a d'la
enfin ça parle de alors c'est là se
livrent les sens de la grèce faites
attention c'est la grèce ancienne ça
s'arrête
ça ça avant la période classique
enfin au démarrage de la période
classique ça s'arrête en 500 avant notre
ère donc c'est pour les sitcoms que nos
sauces miss aisne
vous aurez tel un petit peu aussi voilà
il faut pas voilà faut pas s'attendre à
du classique là dedans mais c'est très
intéressant c'est à dire que c'est
difficile de comprendre la période
classique si on n'a pas compris ça mais
en même temps si vous regardez odyssée
sauvage vous pouvez comprendre voilà je
sais d'eux
on n'a pas fini le concours n'importe
quoi ouais digressions direction numéro
chez moi j'ai pas avec mais ils tiennent
direction des tac tac mais j'ai fait
combien de questions attendent et je
compte 1 2 3 4 5 ha oui si c'est bon tu
ici
ok c'est parti alors comment s'appelle
attention on est reparti concours
remettez-vous dans le bar la chercher
dans vos dans vos souvenirs
comment s'appelle le second temple de
l'acropole donc celui qui efface au
parthénon attention l'orthographe compte
donc le second temple de l'acropole le
voilà et il faut que ce soit bien écrire
et des voûtes google un jeu j'ai rien
contre 1 oui les actes et yonne m le
maudit
quel magnifique pseudo très bien m le
maudit c'est parti
bravo nike tn c'est donc le temple avec
toutes les cariatides qu'à une
architecture complètement loufoque
bravo bravo et donc d'ailleurs j'ai pris
pas mal de bouquins référence c'est
l'occase si vous êtes mort d'une
architecture mais alors là c'est
normalement c'est un bouquin qu'on a
pour la fac
1 c'est le truc que tu dois apprendre
par coeur et que tu oublies une fois le
partiel le passé mais du coup vous avez
toute l'explication de l'iréc theron
comment s'est construit signé voilà
larchitecture tout ce qui est technique
ça vous intéresse à voir comment all fc
pierre combien ça pèse combien ça coûte
de construire un temple
il ya un petit livre qui est donc bah là
pour le coup très très accessible et qui
est vraiment la référence tout le monde
a en archéologie celle architecture
grecque par marie-christine elle
actuellement c'est une archéologue
autrice professeur d'université
ça c'est un petit livre qui au format
poche qui coûte 7 euros 50
vous avez vraiment mal après voilà c'est
lourdingue
c'est avec quelques photos d'archivés et
vous avez beaucoup de plans voilà vous
avez pas mal de plans
c'est faux faux être mordu faut faut
travailler sur le sujet n'est donc pas
voilà moi je je je l' ai toujours eu
pour mes études ce livre c'est des
données qui sont qui changeront pas
c'est la base de la base voilà mais des
fois ça va loin c'est c'est un manuel
d'architecturé mais c'est très
intéressant
c'est un support de court oui
complètement
mais comme c c'est quand même ça se
comprend
je vous le donne tu joue de la guitare
j'apprends jeux gratuits voilà je leur
ai rien de rien de fou fou
tu voudrais pas le livre de françois
xavier machin faubel en pdf
je peux l'avoir de magna le jeu gelé le
j'ai pas mal de livres de françois
xavier faudrait c'est la fin du concours
non ce n'est pas la fin du concours le
concours continue avec la dernière
question à je les aime bien cette
question moi qui les ai écrites à les
dernières questions
donc vous vous souvenez que le site
archéologique de santorin s'appelle
akrotiri voilà et donc la question porte
sur ce site et donc c'est qu'est-ce
qu'on n'a pas retrouvé dans les fouilles
d'akrotiri quel type de vestiges les
archéologues n'ont pas retrouvé
or des gens [ __ ] ça va être dur bon
c'est du laus je te le donner à toi
parce que bon je vais te le dire assez
de l'ofc que tout vaut toutes les
réponses sont à peu près semblable
donc c'est dû aussi oui tout à fait ce
sont autant je note c'est du laus oui on
n'a pas trouvé de deux vestiges humains
donc de de deux cores feinte de corps de
squelettes de restes osseux de de
cheveux on a on n'a absolument rien
trouvé à la différence de de pompéi
ah bah oui c'est sûr henry des soucoupes
volantes on n'en a pas trouvé enfin
quoique selon certaines théories il se
pourrait que le temps est ce que il faut
encore être sérieux à 20h53 pas sur ma
bravo bravo isabelle grégoire le barbant
léo entonnant m le maudit c'est du los
bravos vous m'envoyer un mail où vous me
contacter en message privé en donnant
votre adresse postale et je vous envoie
ça dans la semaine
voilà c'est cool et puis on se refera
leur fera un petit concours de fin de
série vous inquiétez pas bravo bravo et
puis bravo à tous les autres qui nous
aident plein avoir donné la bonne
réponse mais aulas et les concours
etienne une question qui n'a rien à voir
easton indie estonie donc oui chaîne
youtube très très intéressante dit que
la sexualité ça présente de manière
différente chez les romains il ne se
définissent pas comme hétéros homos
qu'en est il des grecs alors je ne suis
absolument pas spécialisés la question
mais dans l'antiquité
ce qu'on peut dire antiquités
méditerranéenne gréco romaine
l'homosexualité est une vertu c'est
quelque chose qui notamment distingue
l'élite
voilà plus vous êtes riche aux places et
plus vous avez intérêt à avoir un petit
jeune a beau côtés de sa fiancée
homosexualité est bon c'est des termes
qui sont anachroniques pédophilie
c'est-à-dire que vous aurez voilà des
jeunes notamment les empereurs romains
mais aussi les
notamment des philosophes ou des
sénateurs grecs peuvent avoir des sortes
de d'élèves c'est une relation très
spéciale où ils les éduque il les
cultivent mais à tous les niveaux que ce
soit intellectuel mais aussi charnel
voilà
alors alexis on sait si c'est à cause
d'une mauvaise techniques de fouilles ou
parce que malgré de bonnes techniques on
a effectivement pas retrouvé de restes
humains
je sais pas si c'est compréhensible donc
c'est par rapport à akrotiri non en fait
pour l'acro thierry s'il y avait eu des
restes osseux des corps humains qui
s'était fait ensevelies on l'aurait vu à
l'âme de la même manière que pompéi
parce que on retrouve par exemple
retrouve de l'organique et du vestige
organique du bois on retrouve des tables
on retrouve des montants de lit donc on
aurait retrouvé comme à pompéi non pas
des vestiges du dieu de l'os mais je
sais nous expliquer sa d'une égale la
trace des corps les négatifs on va
repenser à mon pays mon pays quand vous
voyez les corps ce que vous voyez c'est
du plâtre d'accord les archéologues ont
mis au point une technique qui est à la
fois très pratique mais hyper ingénieuse
avant de fouiller
ils ont fait des trous et ils ont fait
couler du plâtre et ensuite ce plâtre à
sécher et il s'est évidemment infiltrés
dans les dents les dans les trous dans
les trous créés par la présence des
corps d'accord donc ces espèces de
fossiles enfin deux fossiles créé par le
plâtre donc vous n'avez plus que
l'empreinte si vous voulez le négatif et
donc à akrotiri on aurait pu faire cette
technique je pense qu'elle a été testé
d'ailleurs
oui elle a été testée pour notamment les
troncs d'arbres les troncs d'arbres
cession du plâtre qui a été coulé dans
les dents les troupes et qui a pris la
forme du négatif de l'arbre mais à
akrotiri aucun vestige humain donc ça
veut dire que les humains se sont enfuis
ils ont eu le temps de partir de l'île
alors par bateau ici on peut penser
qu'ils sont morts durant la traversée
parce que l'explosion ben franchement
est là
elle a eu des répercussions vraiment sur
toutes les îles autour et il n'y a pas
eu
vous avez sur wikipédia l'article sur la
croûte série est très bien fait il est
très bien vous avez toute la chronologie
donc dix jours avant un séisme
une semaine avant un autre séisme voilà
il ya des vraiment des prémices à cette
grosse éruption volcanique qui vraiment
a évidemment alerter les populations et
elles se sont toutes en fuite on n'a
même pas on n'a pas non plus de
d'animaux n'a pas retrouvé le chemin des
chèvres de chiens voilà ils sont partis
avec ça lui est un peu larges zones quoi
cette affaire
mais voilà il est probable que beaucoup
soient morts en mer l'archéonaute salut
c'est vrai car culhane homme a bien plus
souffert que pompéi non herculanum si
vous avez l'occasion d'aller visiter
cette région
je vous conseille fortement de ne pas
louper herculanum qu'ils aillent bien
mieux été conservées que mon pays
moi j'ai été beaucoup plus touchés par
hercules un homme que par mon pays il ya
une hauteur de mur il ya des détails à
des peintures
c'est vraiment au niveau du détail est
beaucoup plus de choses c'est alors
c'est plus petit évidemment mais c'est
moins monotone pompéi assez monotone
avait du mur de briques de briques de
vrai qu'au bout d'un moment
archéologue ou pas c'est chiant quoi
enfin vous abandonnez vous décrochez
alors qu'elles reculaient ne peut
vraiment profiter des lieux c'est
beaucoup plus à l'échelle d'une d'une
visite touristique et en plus c'est
hyper bien conservé
alors c'est pourquoi c'est du lot ce
pourquoi on n'a pas de trace écrite de
l'événement qui était chez les égyptiens
et les babyloniens ça j'en sais rien
peut-être qu'il ya une source écrite pas
ma connaissance en tout cas je suis pas
pendant mes lectures je suis pas tombé
dessus mais parce que déjà on n'écrit
pas en fait
en enfin on n'écrit pas un petit peu et
des tablettes d'argile mais c'est plus
pour les comptes c'est plus
administratif il n'y a pas du récit
écrit les récits se font par les
fresques par la céramique et par ses de
la transmission orale
ces périodes là
pourquoi utile à l'olivier mort pourquoi
est il probable que beaucoup aient péri
en mer s'ils ont eu le temps de s'enfuir
pour akrotiri santorin parce que
l'explosion du volcan
elle a propulsé 50 kilomètres cubes de
magma dans l'atmosphère donc il ya eu un
tsunami
on voit vraiment surtout quand vous
allez en grèce sur n'importe quelle île
des cyclades
mais même en turquie en crête sur les
côtes du péloponnèse côte est ce vous
avez sur la plage vous allez vous
baigner
vous trouverez toujours de la pierre
ponce des petits galets de pons ils
proviennent de l'explosion de santorin
il faut imaginer que c'est une des plus
grosses catastrophes naturelles de la
préhistoire des temps anciens
ça c'est c'est ça évidemment ça a marqué
des générations et des générations
d'humains et donc c'est difficile quand
on part sur des barques
à l'époque les barques c'est
rudimentaire et puis on l'est on les les
us jusqu'à jusqu'à ce que ce qu'est ce
qu'on coule franchement donc en plus sa
navigation dans les cyclades année pas
facile il ya des courants on peut pas
aller d'une île à une autre faut faire
des espèces de on perd beaucoup de temps
la navigation dans les cyclades
donc même s'ils sont arrivés sur une
côte jeu même s'ils ont fait 100 km au
sud est qui sont arrivés en crète
bah ils ont un peu morflé donc peut-être
que évidemment peut-être qu'ils lui
certains survivants mais bon
oui puis à des plus de roche mon show il
ya la totale c'est
ah bon
bon ah ça fait une heure et demi qu'on
est là s'était séparé est-ce que j'ai
autre chose à vous sur lequel j'aimerais
revenir
écoutez si vous voulez d'inde et si vous
avez d'autres questions à les y va on va
bientôt se quitter ouais merci pour les
dons c'est très très très gentil merci
un petit solo de guitare j'ai jamais
fait ça et j'ai jamais déjà je ferai pas
de solo parce que je ne suis pas capable
de faire des solos j'ai jamais joué
devant des gens vous allez me
ok donc ce qu'ont gagné le concours vous
m'écrivez un petit message pour les
autres sachez que la photographie le
pin's sont en vente il ya une boutique
que j'ai créée sur etsy ou là vous avez
gfm faire un lot pin's et cartes à 15
euros je crois un peu plus avec les
frais de port non c'est ça voilà vous
pouvez acheter ou la carte ou le pin's
ou les deux à la fois
vous paierez moins les frais de port si
vous achetez les deux à la fois
voilà c'est une boutique aussi il ya
quelques photographies de ce tournage
voilà
non il ne reste pas de tee shirt à
vendre tous au delà de la campagne ont
été ont été envoyés il n'en reste pas et
est du coup en fait j'ai fait le truc un
peu un peu bateau de créer une boutique
natif enfin sûr sur youtube
mais je comprends que personne n'achète
sûr sur youtube parce que l'argent ne
revient pas en totalité mais c'est
toujours un peu compliqué de faire un
stock de tee-shirts
si je suis pas sûr de les vendre parce
que ça coûte ça coûte super cher en fait
de faire fabriquer soi-même tout en
france pour pour l'odyssée les t-shirts
ça a coûté presque 500 euros de t-shirts
donc évidemment ça a généré beaucoup de
dons et c'est chouette aussi de faire
des objets de campagne mais mais du coup
voilà je je suis un peu car ce même la
chef de l'état je sais pas trop
alors j'en vois un message avec le type
pour lui dire que je te propose à ma
place il faut donc que tu lui envoie un
mail à isabelle refile le cas d'aucune
aide
ça va être une embrouille là moi je suis
je fait votre tambouille fait vous
faites votre commerce
on y va on est on est hostile à tout le
monde arrive ça c'est une blague
d'historiens c'est donc isabelle devient
l'archéonaute basse est très bon mais
c'est très bien faites vos fait d'être
tambouille j'ai une question xavier
concernant retour elle pas vers le paléo
est ce qu'il y a des exemplaires
dédicacés
si je les dédicaces il n'y a pas de
dédicace on puisse de prévu alors en
sachant que les soirées de projections
qui vont être enfin déjà celle de liant
le 30 septembre
si vous voulez venez avec vos livres vos
soutif ce que vous voulez je les
dédicaces vos cartes mythologique
dédicaces et retrouver le palais own
enfin il faut qu'on se rencontre et que
je le dédicace est pour l'instant si je
serai normalement présentes à narbonne
en octobre pour parler de ce livre
donc c'est un moment de dédicaces je
serai aussi présente
le 4 septembre à paris mais ses fans
c'est un événement qui est ouvert aux
doctorants c'est le comme ciconne voilà
où je peux aussi délicat c'est
possibilité oui bape si vous situer
xavier 8,1 livres et wayne que je le
dédicace
ben je sais pas tu view comment on fait
je peux te le petit peu mots c'est
difficile à faire
je peux m'envoyer ton libre et je te le
retour en dédicace et c'est possible
c'est pas si tu paye des frais de port
aucun problème je te dédie casteu le
renvoi bonne soirée
bonne soirée à ceux qui partent c'était
très très chouette c'est live merci
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
le prochain épisode donc il sort mais
j'ai dit n'importe quoi dans les dates
moi tout à leur jeu il sort le 20
juillet projection à lyon le 30 je vous
remets le lien serait bien que j'arrive
à remettre le lien
si vous voulez participer à la
projection de la série intégralité en
fait c'est un format long non coupée
avec quelques remontage et la présence
de toute l'équipe
l'illustrateur le musicien mon co auteur
et co réalisateur on répond à vos
questions puis c'est une soirée voilà on
va essayer de passer une bonne soirée
ensemble
ce sera à lyon le 30 septembre dans une
super salle c'est un super endroit trop
trop contente et si vous avez bas des
plans pour d'autres villes en france et
en belgique et ben n'hésitez pas à me
i'm sollicités moi non moi je suis
vraiment intéressé pour venir vous voir
vous trouvez voilà passer une bonne
soirée merci
albon lien avec quand on fait comment on
fait mais je m'énerve
voilà non mais j'irai j'arrive ici à
réussir et le lien voilà ça c'est le bon
ben voilà donc si vous voulez venir la
soirée de projection le 30 septembre
inscrivez vous sur ce formulaire
il n'y a pas grand chose c'est juste
pour que je sache un petit peu qui vient
pour ceux qui ont participé à la
campagne
ulule ce sera gratuit ou faut que je
vois en fait ou alors s'il faudra juste
adhérer à l'association en fait parfois
c'est juste légal pour rentrer dans les
lieux d'une association et bénéficier
aussi des tarifs pour la boisson pour
manger qui sont souvent un peu moins
cher il faut juste payer le l'entrée à
l'adhésion à la somme et ses quelques
euros ces trois entre 3 et 5 euros je
crois
et oui je vous tiendrai au courant de
tout mais participations à des festivals
convention il y en aura plusieurs à la
rentrée et je veux oui je vous je vous
tiendrai au courant sur n'hésitez pas à
dérouler les bars d'infos sous les
vidéos youtube notamment si vous n'êtes
pas sûr si vous suivez pas sur instagram
instagram c'est là où je suis le coup je
partage le pain jeu où je viens assez
régulièrement
je tiendrai au courant
merci beaucoup ça m'a vraiment fait
plaisir de parler avec vous ça fait du
bien quand on est dans sa grotte depuis
deux ans avec ce projet et et merci non
mais vraiment merci beaucoup
parce que franchement ce projet ben
genre je dois beaucoup à vous voilà
c'est même pas une question financière
c'est voilà le fait qu' il y ait une
présence qui est du répondant qui est
des gens commentaires que en plus que ça
vous plaise c'est c'est une grande
grande chance passer une bonne soirée
peut-être y aura de la guitare pour un
second life faut que je m'entraîne c'est
tout chaud ça va être un bazar total je
vous embrasse bien fort bonne soirée à
la prochaine
salut